so this is a department of homeland
security advisory that they put out i
believe on february 7th yep alerting us
to a hazard to the homeland that we
should all be aware of okay i think we
should start at paragraph three
paragraph three reads the united states
remains in a heightened threat
environment fueled by several factors
including an online environment filled
with false or misleading narratives and
conspiracy theories and other forms of
diss and mal information whoa mdm
introduced and or amplified by foreign
and domestic threat actors these threat
actors seek to exacerbate societal
friction to sow discord and undermine
public trust in government institutions
to encourage unrest which could
potentially inspire acts of violence
mass casualty attacks and other acts of
targeted violence conducted by loan
offenders and small groups acting in
furtherance of ideological beliefs and
or personal grievances pose an ongoing
threat to the nation
okay now notice
that they this is the first time i'm
seeing this this is
terrorism that they are talking about
and their point is that there are
foreign actors oh yes and domestic
actors who are spreading
miss
diss and mal information what the hell
is mal information should i so we'll get
there okay and um
these threat actors terrorists
are
in a position to create unrest by sowing
the mystics and mal information online
which could potentially inspire
acts of violence
right so that's an amazing amazing
that's a lot of weak links it's a lot of
weak links but you know maybe they're
going to rescue it with mal information
whatever that is maybe mal information
is the concept we have been waiting for
in order to separate the terrorists from
the rest of us
let's see okay so here we go zach we're
back on this page at the
the issuance on february 7th of the
national terrorism advisory system
bulletin now they are very helpfully
hot linked miss disney
scroll down and they will give you a
taxonomy so actually go down a little
more what is mdm
okay so misinformation do you want me
yeah would you read the definition of
misinformation misinformation is false
but not created or shared with the
intention of causing harm so wait some
of these terrorists
are
guilty of spreading misinformation but
it's not intentionally misinformation
they're just kind of you know wrong
doesn't this make
both wolensky and fouchy terrorists no
no no no because they are part of the
federal government that is deploying
everybody knows that they're not terror
come on anthony fauci is a terrorist oh
there's an exclusionary clause
it's not really a clause but it's kind
of a come on right it's a comma no
they're not right so
basically what this does is it defines
as and actually we have no idea about
their intentions
i have no idea no i think their
intentions are good
well then that's it's mere
misinformation that they have right yes
but by the definition so
the science changes we keep on being
told now haven't been led down this
idiotic primrose path to follow the
science and a bunch of us in the
beginning we're like that's not how
science works hello hello hello and now
they're saying well the science changes
so at the point that the science changes
how like what's the what's the period
during which you're allowed to still be
believing the past science
before you convert to the future science
before you are a purveyor of
misinformation and therefore a terrorist
you my dear are missing the glory of mal
information oh i'm not there yet you're
not there yet you have not understood
that although it sounds preposterous
that these people would be defining as
terrorism the
being mistaken and not realizing it and
saying stuff out loud that didn't turn
out to be true that's misinformation
sure sure right let's go to the
disinfectant yeah yeah disinformation is
deliberately created to mislead harm or
manipulate a person social group
organization or country okay so let me
give you an example of uh disinformation
so let's say
that the uh tide corporation
says that you mean like the you mean
like procter and gamble i don't know who
makes tide but you're talking about the
laundry detergent well sure okay okay
let's say for example i don't actually
know if it's productive that they were
to to say
no laundry detergent gets clothes
brighter
than tide right now the fact is
they might say that and it might be
true
but it's meant to mislead you it's meant
for you to hear
that actually tide gets closed brighter
than other detergents when really what
it says is maybe there's no difference
between these detergents they all kind
of do the job right so all advertising i
think all advertising is now terrorism
um
which you know i've always kind of felt
that way about advertising
but um anyway but you know here's the
problem the rubber really meets the road
the whole taxonomy kind of you know so
you've got people who are
uh unintentionally wrong about stuff and
so terrorists here's the thing yeah
i i'm just gonna say it
i have been
unintentionally wrong about stuff what
various points in my life i feel like i
should have known this i feel like you
did know and sometimes you're the person
who points it out but
in any case that puts me squarely in the
crosshairs of this but you know frankly
uh here's the thing though yeah
sometimes
those shoes are on the other feet
it hurts like hell i'm also in the
crosshairs
shoes on the other feet in the
crosshairs it's a mixed metaphor but
we're going with it
um it was your crosshairs metaphor right
but they're my shoes
i have also sometimes been wrong
unintentionally and you have to point it
out okay but therefore i am also in the
crosshairs here's what i'm imagining
many in our audience
we'll also have it who do terrorists
could be so silly
that's the thing they're sneaky sneaky
people and uh you know humor we're gonna
get to humor actually but but here's the
point okay um
many in our audience
will have been wrong at various
occasions right
and do better do better yeah right be
wrong i mean not even less because you
don't want to really be better tennis
while you're at it right okay and then
you know disinformation
that does seem to cover not only
advertising but a huge fraction
of
comedy
you know very poor chip
oh what don't i know
it's been a long time since we were
recording that's true um
no but
you know a charm offensive a make
yourself look better than you i mean
this is what
you know all
all non-human organisms engage in
disinformation crypsis is disinformation
it crept
oh
god you're right yep so it's even
non-human terrorists yeah oh for sure
yeah right um
yep okay but the glory of this really
has it has to be rescued by male
information a term that i think nobody
until this memo had ever heard of right
so it's got to be pretty good it's so
good let's say mal information is based
on fact but used out of context to
mislead harm or manipulate
you got it should i read the last three
lines or should we just stick with that
i think we should uh that's the
definition of the uh
of the male information so this is great
because malin i'm thinking about uh
and indeed i was i was just reminded of
i went back and looked at my fact
checkers aren't scientists piece which
was my very first post on natural
selections
and i walk through
you i think it was you and robert malone
being fact checked in politifact which
is facebook's fact-checking arm just put
that
right like scientists don't belong to
anyone they're not supposed to if
they're doing science but fact checkers
can belong to people
okay
politifact fact-checked you and i
believe it was this claim that got a
pants on fire rating uh that the spike
protein is toxic or cytotoxic
and uh meanwhile research out of scripts
which scripts his own pr
department
posited
said that
spike protein is toxic yeah the spike
protein is tough it's toxic but that
saying that based on fact so for a while
i know it's not no it's not no it's not
and apparently
okay it is but that's mal information
because how dare you talk about that
here right because dare you talk about
it because
what i was trying to do
was raise people's awareness that the
public health authority was misleading
them about safety and the fact that i
was accurate is no defense because i'm
still a terrorist because it doesn't
matter that it's based in fact even true
stuff is mal information that's the
beauty of this definition is that the
fact that it's true is no defense yeah
right how dare you say it yeah it's
okay so misinformation is false
false but accidentally accidentally
false disinformation is is bad
but it includes crips and advertising
and such uh in courtship a lot of it uh
and but male information
just includes
uh it is mal information
is in even more than miss or
disinformation in the eye of the
beholder that's the distinction right
mal information is in the eye of the
beholder and when the eye when the
beholder is the government
and the government gets to behold you
and make a claim about whether or not
you're a terrorist
and
this is it's this is all it needs then
anyone all of you anyone at any time can
be declared to be engaging in terrorism
anyone at any time and that's just the
beginning of the fun oh good um but
let's go back
and map uh
this on to for example
the teaching environment okay let's do
it so
for example let me just point out that i
in teaching
used all three of these techniques i was
sometimes wrong now when i was wrong
somebody would sometimes raise a
question that would reveal that i was
wrong and i would then correct what i
had done but i was still guilty of uh
information terrorism in my teaching let
me just say that another way that
happened for both of us was
um
we'd say something and no one would call
us out because it wasn't no one knew and
then we'd go back to our lives and like
wait um
okay no actually that wasn't right and
then we'd return
of our own
of our own volition and say that thing
that i said was wrong correct your model
yep okay
that's that's that would have been
misinformation misinformation yeah right
in an educational environment right
shame now i was actually voted
misinformation in high school as you'll
recall back when you were a woman
uh no i don't know why i think they were
making fun of me but um
but in any case uh
another in educational environment in
which misinformation was relevant but i
think two s's um
yes disinformation so i used to use
disinformation as a teaching tool
sometimes i would um
you would lead them down a path that you
knew to be wrong i would lead them down
a path that i knew to be wrong and i
would do so
while hinting with my eyebrows or
whatever
that this was a good direction to go so
that they would pick up steam and then
at the point they got someplace i would
start asking them questions like
paradoxes that were raised by all of the
stuff that they just signed on to and
the point is stop
listening to authority stop reading the
social cues pay attention to what
do use your logic
use your analytical and creative
faculties in order to assess what is
right rather than paying attention to
the social cues of the authority in
front of the room
great eyebrows though he may have
some will argue eyebrow but never mind
um
but anyway it was a very useful
technique one does it with humor one
does it with generosity in their heart
nobody ends up upset about it because it
actually ends up educating them and then
mal information of course who doesn't
use mal information in their teaching
because basically mal information
are facts and when you use facts like
let's say the uh
brett's flood scientific calamity right
you teach about how science is a
fallible process and how sometimes your
heretics are actually right and so
anyway all three of these are yeah so
you know two
again mal information the definition out
of the terrorism are with the united
states government which i'm sure is not
how they like to be referred but uh i
think that's basically terroristic no
i'm gonna call it the terrorism arm okay
um
fail information is based on fact but
used out of context to mislead harm or
manipulate and um you know a
two there's a lot hidden in two like how
do you know the intentions of of the
person um but mislead
ought be perhaps a minor crime harm we
don't want people using um facts to harm
others um although obviously it's not as
simple as all of that but manipulate
to manipulate
what were you trying to do i was trying
to manipulate them because they're my
students and i was trying to make them
more educated so that they could see
this sort of thing this sort of tactic
when it is done by people like you
in the future and can be better immune
to it thank you very much how do you
become immune to this sort of thing
except by having been having fallen prey
to it
in the environment that is actually safe
an actually safe environment in which oh
my god i got duped by my professor who's
got great eyebrows how did that happen
like well now you know and now you're
gonna have to do it a number of times
because um you know we all too often
when you when we've been duped once
we've been fooled once by the public
health authorities or the professor or
whatever it is
we take that as the instantiating thing
like that is that is the generalized
thing right and just and i'm reminded of
um this is going to seem like a
non-sequitur but i'm reminded of being
in costa rica um
the second time for us but with a bunch
of grad students and our professor
and we said something and it was the
first time for all the other grad
students but we we had traveled through
central america on our own
a few years earlier and we said
something about well when we were here
before the weather was
and uh professor vandermeer who we're
there with said yeah the first time you
come to a place in the tropics that's
the weather system that you think
is
that year is normal every year
thereafter is not exactly yeah that
that's that's the thing that you then
imagine is normal and there is not a
normal year afterwards and you're always
trying to track what happened
like well what happened was you happened
to arrive at that moment and had you
arrived at any other moment you would
think that was normal
so that you know that's
um we need
we need ourselves to be to expose
ourselves to our own failings and and
failed thinking multiple times because
just doing it once
means that that's the only thing that we
look for and this is actually this is
it's like people looking for jack-booted
thugs for evidence of tyranny right i
mean that's and that's the problem with
with history as well we go oh well i
know i know what tyranny looks like
i've i've i've seen the documentaries
and
no a that's not what it looked like as
it showed up and also it will never look
exactly the same right you have to
familiarize yourself with multiple kinds
and by the way at the point that you've
got some number of people in society who
aren't allowed to participate and are
being slandered as dirty and evil and
not up to the job
that's tyranny coming that is what it is
right and
basically what's protecting them is that
they have learned not to goose step or
put skulls on their helmets this time
right we're we're watching didn't take
much tyranny but you know if that sounds
like an exaggeration we'll get to the
next part but yeah um we're going to
give you links to this memo i would
encourage people to click around this
site we go down to the uh restaurant to
be showing yeah i think mdm resources
i got to say mdm just you know i keep on
expecting the a at the end right exactly
now scroll down you've got a list of mdm
resources war on pineapple yes war on
pineapple is on there i did not hack the
site and put war on pineapple there it's
there of its own accord
but there are other delightful things
okay on this list warren pine i know i
know but uh they do say tangency i this
is the first time i've been here
i'm just looking at a government site
that has border security cyber security
and disasters in the left menu and war
on pineapple and i really don't know
what just because these people
just because these people are just
because they're fascists doesn't mean
they don't know how to have fun
okay
go back to that list of resources
there's a uh there's something about the
quashing rumors
start your own
rumor control page where the rumor
control page oh control page startup
guide sorry
oh so here you've got a nice handy
graphic in which they effectively oh
this one has a bolt mal information has
a bullhorn facts yes that's a bullhorn
broadcasting fact that is nonetheless a
terrorist threat but you want it okay
and the news is the missing good job not
to point me to this before we were on
air what the news is misinformation
right wait uh okay
anyway it's kind of glorious we don't
have time to go through all of this but
it you know it's the site that keeps on
giving this one has the creepy eyes the
creepy scroll down a little bit okay
there's another thing what is a rumor
well a rumor control page is how you can
brown shirt your own site to control
rumors which includes mal information
which are facts
right but presented out of context to
mislead or manipulate context right i
remember correctly am i doing well
you're doing this gonna be on the test
it is the test darling um all right go
over here to uh this uh
myth graphic do you want me to click
yeah would you describe
click it okay it's all right there um it
is it is a
it's got myth
uh with
how do you communicate effectively on a
rumor control page which is again your
brown shirt site just designed to quash
mal information which again are facts
that are presented out of context so as
to uh lead people to understand the
corruption of their federal authority
who put out this document yeah so what
you do is you use a um
a
magnifying
a magnifying glass is the debunking
magnifying glass magic debunking
magnifying glass
it says debunk no it says debunk the
magnifying glass you asked me to
describe it but that's not how you're
going to use it
preemptively debunk or
there you go now wait i haven't even
said it for those listening it says
preemptively debunk or
prebunk yup prebunk yes your federal
authorities are now advocating on your
brown shirt website that you pre-bunk so
as to fend off
facts that are being distributed by
other people
pre-bunk pre-bunk
okay so also preemptively pre-bunking
seems redundant
no it's it's it's pre-debunking i think
no
exactly pre-emptively sl
bunk parenthesis
look and if you don't do that the reason
that you would want to pre-bunk is
because you might have to rebunk right
you're saying
because the science can change well if
somebody debunks your bunk then you're
going to need to rebunk and it's much
better to pre-bunk in order to avoid
that it's that awkward i know that's
what i like to do
okay yeah so your question earlier yeah
about what happens when you're right
and you say the true thing and they say
the wrong thing and then later they have
to admit that they were wrong right
right what was the grace period the
answer is there is no grace period
you're not allowed to contradict them
right even with the facts right right
because that's uh
mal information and that has apparently
not been effectively prebunked right now
among the things that our listeners and
viewers will find on the site which i do
encourage them to look through very
carefully because really it's one jaw
dropping revelation after another is how
blatantly unconstitutional this is
this is a clear violation of the first
amendment and it gets worse because not
only are they encouraging people to
brown shirt against facts right which is
uh
clearly bad but they are also they
willingly acknowledge that what they are
doing is they are partnering with um
people in the private sector you know
tech platforms and the like it's a
private public partnership it's a
private it you know yeah it is largely
innovated by uh
iid with fouchy at oh not innovative
because they had historical precedent
because this of course is the symphony
of fashion not not
innovated but um
made mainstream
publicized with great glory associated
with it by fauci and then head of the
nih columns right now
all of this glorious fascism has a
beautiful cherry on top does it which we
are not going to show do we like
fascistic cherries or do we not well we
like that they are revealing themselves
and while they are not going to
goosestep or put skulls on their hats
they have published a couple of graphic
novels about these
terrorist
misinformers with a nazi hat on now i
think i think it's perfect probably
coming i don't know but anyway do check
out their graphic novels um there's a
graphic novel i i've only looked at one
of them this graphic novel is about i
think it's about 5g conspiracy theorists
but the hero you want me to go back
through here's uh scroll down to the
resources
wait here this or not yeah real fake
graphic novel what does that mean really
well real fake is their first graphic
novel the other graphic novel though is
bytes yeah bug bytes exactly do you want
yeah actually you should you can show
that so this again is mdm not mdma
resources uh in case you were wondering
um yeah i'm i'm not feeling warm or
fuzzy at all well show it bug bites okay
so here is bytes with a y but bytes b y
t s
yeah just scroll through a little bit
disclaimer yeah so this is a graphic
novel now this uh attractive white woman
her father works for a communications
company and was viciously attacked by
terrorists and she terrorists engaging
in malinformation was it well i don't
know it's somehow being distributed by
the people who are exercised about mal
information but if you keep scrolling
down you will see her as the hero of the
story see she puts on her mask here
um
bottom of the page there
right um and then anyway outside look at
her walking alone outside with their
mascot right i know and uh
anyway there's a marvelous trailer for
this uh on youtube which you can click
to uh we're not gonna do it here but
anyway this is hard to parse in in real
time but oh yeah those do look like
terrorists yeah they really do i mean
they are they blew [ __ ] up but um but
the point is but that's but that i mean
that's that's what it leads to that's
like when you hear terrorists you think
people looking like that doing those
sorts of things and that just as i want
to talk about before we if we're done
here today um the image of what the
working class are is you know it's
factory workers uh and you know our our
pat little images of who particular
who belongs to particular categories
is helping us be controlled
and is going to help
you know if if that's what we all have
in our mind oh you're not only showing
the screen but if you know um
bottle rocket hurling
what are those called uh balaclava
wearing no no no the the the explosive
i don't know what explosive right it's
it's a it's oh uh cocktail sorry
yes
so molotov cocktail throwing
terrorists is what we all have in our
heads about what terrorists look like
and then
everyone frankly everyone has just
gotten slotted into at any moment that
we want to we call you a terrorist but
as soon as we do so then this is what is
going to be called up okay in people's
heads so let us
get to where the rubber really meets the
road here because everybody listening to
this is going to say yes okay this is
crazy the federal government is
declaring people even people who are
distributing facts out of what the
federal government decides our context
whatever that means right that those
people are terrorists so yes this is
very ominous stuff
[Music]
you